face à une inflation record l'inflation
l'inflation due à l'inflation pic en
face aux listes ce mot est à la bouche
des gouvernements et institutions mais
jusqu'à quand dans cet épisode de
factures on va essayer de comprendre
comment on pourrait faire baisser
l'inflation
tout d'abord je vous propose qu'on se
demande ce qu'est réellement l'inflation
et à quoi ça correspond
c'est lorsque le prix des biens et des
services augmentent de façon durable
dans le temps l'inflation montre un
dysfonctionnement du marché c'est à dire
que l'offre est plus forte que la
demande ou inversement
mesure l'inflation grâce à l'ipc indice
des prix à la consommation qui est
calculé par l'insee comme on disait en
début de vidéo l'europe et en
particulier la france subissent cette
très forte augmentation des prix à tous
les niveaux mais pourquoi l'impulsion de
départ ça a été à cette hausse
incontrôlée des prix de l'énergie a
déclenché par un la guerre en ukraine
même si on avait quand même connu déjà
un début de frémissement d'inflation
parce qu'on avait une reprise suite à la
période qu'ovide qui avait un peu
étouffé notre économie et qu'en fait on
sait on a retrouvé une activité normale
ça fait un an qu'on appelle un choc d'or
ce faire toutes les usines se sont mis à
se remettre en ordre de marche au même
moment et saints sacrés ca généré à une
certaine forme d'inflation comme besoin
de nous l'expliqué stéphanie byers est
appuyé par cette projection publiée par
la banque de france l'inflation que nous
vivons pourrait s'expliquer tout d'abord
par la crise bucovine puisque nous avons
moins produit à cause de période
le moins répétition et notamment en
chine où les confinements deux sont
toujours d'actualité et par la guerre en
ukraine parce que l'europe cherche à se
désolidariser de la russie concernant
son approvisionnement en énergie la
balance dont on parlait plutôt entre
l'offre qui baisse et la demande qui
reste la même et donc pas équilibré
la france a déjà fait face à une
inflation galopante notamment dans les
années 70 avec deux chocs pétroliers qui
se font particulièrement ressentir à la
pompe cette crise entraînée une période
de stagflation la croissance était
faible le taux de chômage était au et
les prix continuer d'augmenter à cette
époque là les salaires du public et du
privé ont été indexés à cette inflation
il augmente en fonction de
l'augmentation des prix jusqu'en 1983
lors du tournant de la rigueur
aujourd'hui seuls les 2 millions de
français payés au smic qui reste protégé
contre l'inflation grâce à cette
indexation alors pourquoi ne pas
l'étendre à tous les salaires parce que
vous faites lorsque les salaires sont
indexés sur les prix l'entreprise a
tendance à répercuter la hausse des
salaires a sur son pré finale alors dans
ces cas là c'est pour ça qu'on appelle
ça une spirale greenbook les sahraouis
qui reviennent voir l'art entreprises en
disant baru mais il nous faut encore
augmenter le salaire parce que les prix
à des mets en vente et les entreprises
est de nouveau en des salaires et puis
donc voilà c'est la spirale infernale
c'est à dire que ça s'arrête jamais la
solution qui nous semblait être la plus
évidente ne peut donc pas être envisagée
alors quelles sont les clés que nous
avons à portée de main
alors classiquement pour faire baisser
l'inflation en tout cas pour que la
population ne ressente mois les
recensements les effets négatifs vous
avez plusieurs leviers le premier c'est
un effet budgétaires auxquels le
gouvernement aujourd'hui largement
recours donc on va mettre en place une
aide d'urgence de 100 euros par foyer
par ménage est de 50 euros par enfant
qui sera donc à en place à la rentrée
une des solutions qui a d'ores et déjà
été annoncées par le gouvernement et
d'offrir des primes ou des chèques aux
français pour le pouvoir d'achat a été
le plus impacté ce type d' aide permet
d'éviter d'impacter directement
l'employeur et donc de répercuter les
éventuelles hausses sur les ménages une
méthode qui paient la facture donc voilà
donc l'inflation baisse mais il n'y a
pas de magie en économie qui va le payer
les générations futures que l'on perd on
corrompt les dates futur donc c'est une
façon très court terme de lutter contre
l'inflation mais qui permet
politiquement d'éviter trop de tensions
sociales comme la diane de guigné il n'y
a pas de magie en économie alors la bce
à mettre un coup de frein à l'économie
européenne comment est bien en
augmentant les taux d'intérêt c'est à
dire que lorsque les taux sont au les
ménages comme les entreprises achètent
moins et sont d'être membres ont ralenti
l'économie globale problème en
ralentissant l'économie la bce pourrait
provoquer une récession
c'est un réel jeu d'équilibriste dans
lequel se lance christine lagarde la
présidente de la banque centrale
européenne donc c'est très compliqué
très compliqué de jouer avec l'inflation
mais c'est important de faire quelque
chose ceci vous laisser complètement le
marché en liberté vous pouvez arriver à
des phénomènes vraiment très perverse
une inflation en remontant boule de
neige on pourrait penser que c'est la
balance entre l'offre et la demande
s'équilibre à nouveau les prix
reviendront à la normale soit au niveau
avant que vides mais ce ne serait pas
possible non plus pourquoi il ya
beaucoup d'inflation cette année parce
qu'on voulait tout par rapport à l'année
dernière et l'année dernière en fait
notamment les prix d'énergie a été et
est au plus bas leur père en fait était
extrêmement faible parce que en 2021 on
était en début de sortie de crise
sanitaire l'économie était balbutiante
l'inflation était très sale n'avait pas
du tout de hausse des prix qui a ce
rebond à la fois la reprise des échanges
énergétiques
donc forcément il ya un gars l'année
prochaine en 2023 c'est pas tant que les
prix de l'énergie ont continué à être
galopant à la hausse mais continue à une
galopant c'est juste que on va se
retrouver à des niveaux de prix plus
élevés qu'avant la crise un autre point
auquel on pourrait penser c'est à dire
qu'on pourrait annuler l'inflation de la
même manière qu'on annule la dette d'un
pays en proche avec ça dans les voilà
mais toutes les exemples dans le passé
où l'état a voulu fixer les prix
justement ici lutter façon un peu
massive et administratifs que la faction
ça ne fonctionne pas parce que les gens
pour trouver des billets est très
généralement tout ce qui se passe est
immédiatement sa développement très fort
du marché noir est donc nécessaire
d'intervenir soit à l'échelle nationale
ou à l'échelle européenne pour pallier
l'inflation
à terme la solution la plus pérenne
serait de résoudre le problème à la
racine et dans le cas de figure auquel
nous faisons face soit le manque de
diversification de nos ressources
énergétiques
l'europe et la france devraient se
tourner vers des énergies produites sur
le territoire plutôt que d'en importer
comme auparavant donc c'est plutôt
explorer des solutions pour comprendre
que franchement on change d'ère et
qu'aujourd'hui on s'achemine vers une
énergie qui seront beaucoup plus cher
que par le passé
[Musique]